[Musique]
bonsoir à tous c'est parti pour une
nouvelle semaine d'information locale
avec tv soixante dix huit bienvenue dans
cette édition du lundi 10 décembre tout
de suite les titres de ce set 8 journal
les gilet jaune investissent coignières
depuis samedi lé sont mobilisés devant
le dépôt des carburants où a été
installé ce matin un barrage filtrant et
dans ce contexte de contestation
nationale certaines mairies ont ouvert
leurs portes samedi pour recueillir la
parole des citoyens nous en parlons avec
philippe g selon président de
l'association des maires ruraux des
yvelines samedi soir s'est clôturé le
téléthon le week-end marathon pour la
recherche contre les myopathies
l édile de saint quentin en yvelines
était bien sûr de la bataille dans cette
édition premier bilan à magny les
hameaux et montigny le bretonneux
enfin le tour d'horizon des résultats
sportifs du week-end versailles éliminés
avec les honneurs en coupe de france de
football les yvelinois se sont inclinés
au 8e tour contre le rc lens 4 buts à 2
une rencontre bien animé en tribune avec
les jeunes du club et les ultras
versaillais et puis autre invité dans ce
journal stéphane noël directeur de
l'établissement français d'ile-de-france
français du sang à d'île de france est à
suivre tout à l'heure dans ce journal
ils viennent des yvelines mais aussi de
l'eure et loire depuis samedi matin
plusieurs gilet jaune ont entamé une
action devant le dépôt de carburant de
coignières elle devrait se poursuivre
cette semaine
ce matin un barrage filtrant a été
organisée pour ralentir le trafic des
citernes le mouvement pourrait perturber
l l'approvisionnement des
stations-service des yvelines edéa
départements voisins est les personnes
mobilisées ne sont pas satisfaites des
récentes annonces des manuels mâcon
notamment celle de suspendre la hausse
sur les taxes des carburants écoutez le
au micro de nicolas d'andré nous ce
qu'on veut clairement c
la démission de marc qu'on a je pense
qu'on est tous dans le même cas on a un
ras-le-bol général
voilà ça fait un moment que ça dure ça
va faire quand même le week-end prochain
ça fera quand même le cinquième week-end
qu'on est mobilisé il faudrait peut-être
quand on propose des choses claires ya
des gens qui souffrent qui avec 1400
euros c'est pas possible
moi je préconise une un smic à 1800
euros net et non pas bon et net c'est le
minimum pour vivre aujourd'hui c'est pas
possible autrement et on reparlera de
coignières tout à l'heure avec
l'installation du nouveau maire didier
fischer les lui a d'ailleurs rendu
visite aux personnes mobilisées dans la
commune et ce week-end les gilet jaune
se sont également mobilisées en
plusieurs points dans les yvelines au
péage de saint-arnoult sur l'a10 et de
buchelay sur l'a13 vous le voyez sur ces
images où les gendarmes ont organisé des
opérations et saisi plusieurs objets
dangereux est des actions également sur
la seine au niveau de l'éclusé d'andrésy
où une vingtaine de personnes a bloqué
les entrées et sorties fluviale de paris
et à rambouillet le gilet jaune a été
troquée par un costume du père noël
interpellant emmanuel macron et les
automobilistes à l'entrée de la ville
le président de la république qui a
rencontré aujourd'hui à les partenaires
sociaux une allocation allocution
officielle est prévue ce soir à 20
heures pour répondre à la colère des
français
vendredi 15 mai à des yvelines ont été
reçus à l'elysée pour porter un message
de terrain auprès du chef de l'état
pendant plus de trois heures ils ont
échangé avec lui chacun avait sa
thématique les élus ont exhorté emmanuel
macron de s'appuyer davantage sur les
mers premier relais avec la population
et l'ont mise en garde sur le matraquage
fiscal dans la délégation la mère de
plaisir joséphine coleman ce berger qui
a pu parler de l'image du président elle
a été interrogée par nicolas landry
il a compris qu on était pas on ne
souhaitait pas de rencontres
protocolaires uniquement et qu'on
souhaitait les rencontres de
collaboration et de participation avec
un vrai choc chaland on a été plus que
entendu puisque passé trois heures en
tête à tête avec aucun protocole autour
c'est plutôt positif
en tout cas dans la démarche en ce qui
me concerne moi je sais que
mathématiques était l'image les
présidents c'était ça la thématique et
que j'ai défendue et que je les ai
évoqué avec lui sans ambages il s'en est
sans détour sur effectivement ce que
l'on ressentait ce que l'on jeu que l'on
voyait depuis quelques mois je me suis
permis de lui dire des choses assez
assez franches
il a eu une grande élégance de
compréhension en tout cas et d'écouté et
de respect et d'acceptation puisque là
il a accepté des propos qui était fort
et on est allé assez loin dans nos corps
nos disques aux initiatives des élus qui
s'ajoute à d'autres l'association des
maires ruraux de france invitait ses
élus ce samedi à ouvrir leurs portes aux
citoyens afin de recueillir leurs
paroles bonsoir philippe g selon qu'on
soit avec le maire de méricourt vous
êtes également le président de
l'association des maires ruraux des
yvelines alors un mot déjà sur cette
rencontre entre les maires et emmanuel
macron ses quinze élus ont exhorté le
président à davantage s'appuyer sur les
mers qui est qu'ils sont le premier
relais avec la population c'est
primordial aujourd'hui de s'appuyer sur
ces mères je pense que les salles et les
maires ont toujours été un amortisseur
social et il faut redonner la parole aux
élus il faut que emmanuel macron redonne
la parole aux territoires mais ils ont
clairement d'expérience de terrain qui
est très importante
c'est le cas du mans est absolument est
hélas pour cette occasion nous pouvons
être l'oreille du président c'est à dire
que on a vu qu'il y avait une petite
difficulté de dialogue entre les gilet
jaune sur le terrain et le plus haut
sommet de l'état
et là nous nous pouvons servir de relais
faire le lien entre le président et la
base est justement pour servir de relais
l'association des maires ruraux de
france invité ses élus ce samedi à
ouvrir leurs portes aux citoyens afin de
recueillir leurs paroles pourquoi ces
c'est primordial et pourquoi vous avez
organisé cette action
eh bien on s'est rendu compte que dans
nos campagnes
beaucoup de nos concitoyens avaient posé
sur leur tableau de bord gilet jaune
donc voilà j'ai été faire un petit
sondage dans ma commune et beaucoup
m'ont dit mais non moi je manifeste pas
parce que je peux pas je suis trop vieux
etc mais mais par contre je partage je
suis tout à fait d'accord avec ce qui se
passe en soit mangé des revendications à
faire
donc l'idée l'idée de cette opération
mairie ouverte c'est de recevoir des
doléances de nos habitants de libérer la
parole en quelque sorte vous le dis tout
le monde n'a pas forcément son gilet
jaune c'est dire que c'était un
mouvement plus global de contestation de
ras-le-bol peut être en france que vous
avez constaté
oui en fait on voit là nous il ya
longtemps qu'on dénonce le sentiment
d'abandon c'est plus un sentiment
d'ailleurs maintenant c'est un vécu de
la part des pouvoirs publics les
services son public son parti de nos
campagnes
les commerces ont fermé y a pas de
transport et pourtant nos habitants
payent des mêmes impôts que les autres
des dotations aussi qu'ils baissent pour
les communes bien sûr bien sûr les
dotations ce qui fait que et les
regroupements dans des grosses d'interco
qui qui commet qui vident nos communes
de leur sens voilà on éloigne de plus en
plus le pouvoir décisionnaire de
l'habitant et tout ça ça crée un climat
de quelques pas très très bon et on
accumule l'accumulent de la misère de la
souffrance de la colère et un jour ça
paie toi c'est ce qui est en train de se
passer et cet appel à cette opération
mairie ouverte elle a été suivie
il a été suivi par don dans les yvelines
notamment dans votre commune ah oui
alors oui il a été suivi par pas mal de
communes dans les yvelines
rien que chez nous on moi j'avais comme
j'étais un peu à l'initiative du projet
j'avais décidé d'ouvrir ma mairie jeudi
vendredi et samedi matin et on a reçu un
peu moins de 600 personnes
vous êtes venu avec le cahier de
doléances chine d'ailleurs avec le
cahier de doléances alors dans lequel on
a on a ce que vous avez pu vous y
recueillir les principales choses qui
reviennent alors les principales choses
c'est la taxe la suppression de la taxe
carbone l'augmentation du smic
la revalorisation des retraites à la
suppression de la taxe carbone a priori
c'est face à ces faits la suppression de
la csg de l'augmentation de la csg sur
les retraites mais aussi beaucoup de
témoignages et notamment beaucoup de
témoignages de personnes qui travaillent
et qui n'arrivent plus à vivre de leur
travail
voilà j'ai même mieux une personne qui
m'a dit moi je me mets en maladie à
partir de la troisième semaine du mois
parce que j'ai pu les moyens de mettre
de l'essence dans le réservoir
c'est à dire des populations vous ai
reçus des habitants qui sont vraiment
gens qui sont au smic mais qui doivent
faire 60 80 km par jour alors aller
retour ça fait cent soixante voilà avec
toutes les augmentations parce qu'il
n'ya pas que ça il ya les mutuelles
il ya des histoires du 80 km/heure donc
les gens qui roulent plus que les autres
sont plus susceptibles de se prendre des
amendes et voilà tout ça ça ça crée un
climat avait l'impression qu'on tape
toujours sur les mêmes la suite c'est de
remettre ses propositions de les faire
remonter peut-être au gouvernement avec
l'association des maires ruraux de
france on collationne toutes ces
réclamations
on est en train justement de faire un
petit peu
ménage dans tout ce qu'on a reçu on va
transmettre ça alors nous aux
parlementaires et aux préfets et
l'association des maires ruraux de
france rarement très sérieux à la
présidence de la république
il y aura d'autres opérations mairie
ouverte est ce que c'est prévu alors
pour le coup vu le grand succès qu'on a
rencontrés là on laisse les merlus
ouverte jusque jusque samedi prochain le
d'accord alors à l'heure où nous
enregistrons ce journal il est 18 heures
10 emmanuel macron donc doivent faire
des annonces doit faire en tout cas un
discours à 20h à la population pour
tenter de calmer ces tensions qui sont
exacerbées depuis le 17 novembre et le
début de cette contestation des gilets
jaunes deux groupes de gilet jaune
appelle d'ailleurs à se mobiliser à
nouveau samedi prochain que doit dire le
président ce soir pour calmer en tout
cas là la colère n'a voté moi de
président il doit dire aux français qui
les a entendus ça c'est la première des
choses ensuite il doit envoyer des
messages forts mais bon on sait bien on
est en période de fêtes mais le
président de la république c'est quand
même pas le père noël
donc il faudra annoncer des choses
qu'ils soient qu'ils soient qui soit
acceptable qui soit possible mais il
faut en tous les cas envoyer un message
très fort à nos habitants et notamment
aux habitants des communes rurales qui
souffrent je pense un peu plus que les
autres
donc voilà s'il vous plaît monsieur le
président redonner la parole aux
territoires redonner vous avez besoin de
nous et nous on a besoin de vous et on
en revient à ce qu'on disait en début
d'entretien s'appuyer davantage sur les
mers c'est essentiel absolument nous
sommes nous sommes l'amortisseur social
le jour on est bons joue plus ce rôle là
eh bien on arrive à des situations de
crise comme on connaît aujourd'hui
merci philippe gesland être passé sur ce
plateau président de l'association des
maires ruraux des yvelines vous êtes
également le maire de la commune de
méricourt le reste de l'actualité en
bref carlos ghosn mise en examen au
japon le patron du groupe renault basées
notamment à guyancourt est poursuivi
pour dissimulation de revenus perçus
chez nissan entre 2010 et 2015 dans le
cadre de l'alliance avec renault et
mitsubishi
il aurait omis de déclarer 38 millions
d'euros au fisc japonais depuis trois
semaines il est incarcéré à tokyo sa
garde à vue a été prolongée pour
d'autres accusations similaires sur une
période plus récente la suite du procès
en appel de francis heaulme le tueur en
série comparé à versailles pour le
double meurtre d'enfants à montigny les
metz en moselle en 1986 crime pour
lequel il avait été condamné à la
perpétuité en première instance
une journée de lundi marquée par
l'audition en visio conférence de
patrick dils condamné puis acquitté dans
cette affaire après 16 ans
d'emprisonnement verdict du procès en
appel attendu pour le 21 décembre et à
versailles toujours les avocats du
barreau des yvelines en grève devant le
palais de justice ce matin comme
plusieurs de leurs confrères en france
ils sont vent debout
vent debout pardon contre le projet de
réforme de la justice portée par la
ministre et garde des sceaux nicole
belloubet le texte doit être
définitivement voté à l'assemblée
nationale ce mercredi une 32e édition
suivie comme d'habitude à saint quentin
en yvelines le téléthon s'est achevée
samedi soir pendant deux jours un
véritable marathon pour récolter des
fonds en faveur de la recherche contre
les maladies et génétiques rares premier
bilan à magny les hameaux et montigny le
bretonneux avec aurélie rose retour dans
la bonne humeur pour ses trente six
randonneurs qui ont marché durant trois
heures dans la vallée
cette randonnée pédestre de 8 km était
l'un des temps forts de cette édition
2010 8 du téléthon à manille mes amours
ans participe depuis 11 ans au téléthon
bas pour l'esprit l'esprit du téléthon
c'est pour une bonne cause donc on est
là on est présent la ville avait retenu
comme thème cette année la chine se sont
succédé pendant 24 heures des
démonstrations de danse ou encore des
concerts tout était au profit de
l'association française contre les
myopathies
si les promesses de dons ont chuté cette
année au niveau national les recettes à
manille elle reste stable par rapport
aux années précédentes
dix neuf mille quatre cent cinquante
deux euros ont été récoltés pour nous
l'essentiel c'est que ce soit un moment
festif un absolument et ce moment festif
c'est faire venir les gens dans le dans
le gymnase qui prennent conscience
viennent s'amuser mais pour une très
belle cause
bilan positif également à montigny le
bretonneux
le complexe sportif pierre de coubertin
accueilli 1100 personnes
pour ces journées solidaires les enfants
ont pu s'initier à plusieurs ateliers
sportifs comme par exemple le handball
ça permet d'aider et puis en plus ça ne
s'est pas montré une bonne image
de la partition de l'ensemble des
associations justement dans un événement
en tout 65 associations unies montaigne
étaient présentes pour cette édition
2010 8
ça fait partie des incontournables de
l'année ça nous fait plaisir d'être
présent et je crois que ça fait plaisir
à tous nos adhérents de se montrer et de
venir faire un petit cirque en famille
on avait beaucoup mieux nous espérons
battre les sudo l'année dernière
maintenant on verra après voilà les
comptes se sera pas tout de suite les
chiffres définitifs seront connus à la
fin du mois montigny l'opération
caritative
elle se poursuit sur internet autre
appel à la mobilisation et la solidarité
l'établissement français du sang lance
un appel dès à présent aux dons en
prévision à des fêtes de fin d'année
vont soir stéphane noël
bonsoir vous êtes le directeur régional
de l'établissement français du sang
d'île de france alors pourquoi lancer
cet appel c'est cette période juste
avant les fêtes c'est une période
particulièrement sous tension écoutez
c'est une période qui est habituellement
sous relative tension nous sommes à
l'approché des fêtes de fin d'année
qu'on à laquelle les donneurs donne un
petit peu moins pendant cette période de
fêtes c'est une période
au sortir de laquelle habituellement
nous savons d épidémie importante et
donc nous devons impérativement en
prévision de ces différents événements
réhaussé notre niveau de stocks cette
année nous avons fait un appel aux dons
il nous souhaitons faire un appel aux
dons renforcé par rapport à ce que nous
faisons habituellement tout simplement
parce que la situation aujourd'hui est
véritablement sous tension notre stock
national aujourd'hui et aux alentours de
85 mille produits alors que nous
devrions être aux alentours de 100 mille
produits à cette période de l'année
et comment allez-vous vous l'avais dit
la peur peut-être face aux épidémies
saisonnières il ya aussi ce mouvement
des jeunes peut-être qu'ils les
personnes sont mobilisées sur d'autres
causes que le don du sang en cette fin
d'année différentes causes et se
cumulent les unes avec les autres
effectivement
le mouvement que nous connaissons ce
mouvement au sein de la société ralenti
la collecte par rapport à ce que nous
faisons d'habitude nous avons par
exemple été contraint d'annuler des
collectes en lice et suite à certains
mouvements de manifestations qui sont
organisées dans des lycées etc etc et
l'ensemble de ses causes mises bout à
bout nous amène aujourd'hui à solliciter
de manière renforcée
les donneurs en général nous avons
besoin de tous les donneurs et s'il vous
plaît si vous êtes de groupe o o positif
et surtout au négatif
nous avons vraiment besoin de vous
l'appel est lancé vous le disais l'état
actuel des stocks est très bas l'état
actuel des stocks est tendue quand nous
arrivons à faire face naturellement mais
notre objectif est toujours de prévoir
de prévoir la suite de prévoir l'avenir
il nous faut aujourd'hui véritablement
renforcer nos stocks
donc je le répète nous avons besoin de
vous tous tous les groupes sanguins mais
surtout si vous êtes au au positif et
surtout encore plus négatif nous avons
vraiment besoin de vous on le rappelle à
chaque nouveau venu ici sur ce plateau
c'est important de le dire
ces stocks de produits sanguins doivent
être renouvelés constamment ces îles
sont limitées dans le temps ces produits
sont bien exactement les produits
sanguins ont une durée de vie limitée
cinq jours pour les plaquettes 42 jours
pour les concentrés de globules rouges
ce qui explique que nous sommes tout le
temps dans l'obligation de renouveler
les produits qui ont été consommée la
veille
ces produits sont absolument
indispensables pour des patients qui
sont atteints de cancers de leucémies
ces produits sont indispensables pour
une jeune maman qui éventuellement va
faire une hémorragie au moment de
l'accouchement
ces produits sont indispensables en
perspective de la prise en charge de
personnes qui auraient des accidents de
la route
en perspective de chirurgie à lourdes
donc ces produits sont indispensables
pour tout le monde et on l'entend dans
vos propos ça sauve des vies d alice of
des vies tout à fait ça sauve des vies
que de donner son sang 12 kwh est le
héros d'un jour en donnant votre sang et
ont souvent une vie grâce aux dons de
sang
et pour assurer la pérennité des stocks
c'est combien de don de sang qu'il
faudrait par jour alors en france il
nous faut dix mille dons par jour pour
donner votre sang vous pouvez trouver le
lieu de collecte sur notre site internet
du ffs point sante.fr ou dont 200 points
fs - sante.fr actuellement nous savons
les deux et à partir de ce site internet
vous pouvez trouver le lieu de collecte
que plus proche
vous soit un site fixe soit une collecte
mobile il y en a partout d'organiser sur
le territoire national et en particulier
partout dans notre région francilienne
et partant de là vous pouvez choisir le
lieu de collecte le plus approprié en
fonction de votre mode de vie
d'autant plus rappelons le que donner
son sang c'est très rapide
on pourrait croire que ça pourrait
mobiliser une demi journée une journée
entière mais non c'est très rapide de
données sans donner son sang c'est très
rapide très rapide
les conditions pour donner son sang
c'est très simple globalement il faut
avoir plus de 18 ans il faut être en
bonne santé peser plus de 50 kg donc
d'aider des contraintes très simple à
réaliser et d'autre part donner son sang
est assez rapide
grosso modo il faut compter une heure
pour donner son sang l'acte de
prélèvement lui même dur un petit quart
d'heure entre le moment où vous arrivez
le moment où on vous libère après avoir
bien pris soin de vous réhydrater et
bien il faut compter une petite heure et
en une petite heure vous avez réalisé un
acte absolument indispensable pour
autrui vous parliez tout à l'heure des
besoins sur certains groupes en
particulier ce qu'on peut donner si on
ne connaît pas son groupe
bien sûr tout le monde peut donner et
même si on ne connaît pas son groupe
connaître son groupe n'est pas
indispensable
il faut donner quelque soixante groupes
tous les groupes sont importants tous
les groupes sont importants et de fait
même si j'ai mis l'accent sur les
groupes o qui sont vraiment
indispensables aujourd'hui nous avons
besoin de tous les groupes sanguins à b
ou qu'ils sont tous absolument
indispensable pour faire face aux
besoins des patients on rentre dans la
dernière minute de cet entretien un
appel à lancer vous l'avez fait tout à
l'heure peut-être à renouveler aux
franciliens aux yvelinois qui nous
regardent et m'écoutent et un appel
annoncé je le redis aujourd'hui nous
avons un stock au niveau national qui
est tendu nous devons faire face et nous
devons anticiper les évènements de qui
arrive cette fin d'année une période de
moindre dons pendant les vacances de fin
d'année une période plus difficile début
janvier avec des épidémies possiblement
des intempéries de la neige et c est
notre rôle notre devoir à tous nous
établissement français du sang vous
d'honneur c'est d'anticiper ces périodes
là pour que nous soyons en permanence en
totale sécurité pour en permanence faire
face aux besoins des patients et toutes
les informations qui sont à retrouver
sur le site internet qui s'est affichée
tout au long de cet entretien merci à
stéphane noël d'avoir été avec nous
directeur régional de l'est
tablissements français du sang d'île de
france une semaine après le second tour
des élections municipales de coignières
didier fischer a pris officiellement ce
dimanche ses nouvelles fonctions de
maire de la commune est le conseil
d'installation s'est déroulée dans le
calme en mairie les images de michael et
demi d'euros le commentaire daury des
roses avec 22 votes pour et cinq votes
blancs c'est sans surprise en ce
dimanche 9 décembre que le conseil
municipal de coignières a élu didier
fischer maire de la ville beaucoup
d'émotion sur un conseil d'installation
c'est aux mesures on mesure les
responsabilités qui sont maintenant les
nôtres un toute l'équipe
nous sommes en responsabilité là depuis
quelques minutes
sa liste nouvel élan pour coignières
avait remporter la municipale partielle
avec +2 58% des suffrages contre 41%
pour la liste menée par ali bousselham
l'opposition qui prône l'apaisement pour
cette nouvelle ère tout en étant bien
présente
on va laisser le temps au temps mais
nous serons là nous sommes
nous sommes également représentant d'une
partie de la population et nous
veillerons à ce que tous les canadiens
puissent vivre mieux encore le vivais au
jour la première action pour didier
fischer en tant que nouveau maire sera
de couvrir les écoles aux parents
j'espère que le lundi 17
les parents pourront notamment les
parents de maternelle accompagné leurs
enfants jusqu'aux jusqu'à la porte de la
place c'est une demande c'est une
demande des parents aujourd'hui pas vous
savez il ya il ya effectivement un plan
vigipirate renforcé mais bon je pense
que l'on peut quand même se permettre
cela aujourd'hui
prochain rendez vous pour l'équipe
municipale le conseil du 18 décembre
pour désigner les délégations des huit
adjoints au maire et vous l'attendez
sans doute avec impatience le lundi
c'est le jour de la chronique sport de
michael et demi d'euro bonds soir en
soir et pour parler pour commencer cette
chronique sport du football la coupe de
france
on l'a joué ce week-end exactement
grégory à 8e tour de la coupe de france
versailles qui évolue en nationale 3 a
failli réaliser le plus bel exploit de
son histoire ce samedi 8 décembre devant
plus de 3000 à supporters les hommes de
la cité royale se sont inclinés 4 à 2
face au racing club de lens un club de
ligue 2 après avoir réussi à mener au
score une déception pour le staff
versailles et et les joueurs il était au
micro à votre micro des griquas oui tout
à fait malgré tout et la défaite donc
l'année c est parce qu on a abordé ce
match là pour par le remporter
on n'a pas remporté ce match mais je
tiens à saluer le courage l'abnégation
et le coeur que mes joueurs ont mis sur
ce match au fil du match et cette
seconde mi temps on a on a pris un but
assez vite mais on a on a baissé
physiquement et c'est là où c'était plus
dur pour nous très très belle ambiance
en tout cas rien pour ce 8e tour de
coupe de réclamer les ultras et est au
rendez vous toujours avec l'élimination
l'élimination de versailles les
yvelinois nos comptes plus
malheureusement aucun représentant en
coupe de france rendez vous l'année
prochaine pour vivre de nouvelles
émotions et on a hâte de les retrouver
c'est vers ça y est les prochaines coupe
de france et on va d'ailleurs suivre là
le reste de leur saison en nationale 3
du rugby à présent un derby à
rebondissements entre chevreuse et le
sky rugby dans le championnat honneur
plus fort physiquement les chevrotins
archi favori de la rencontre ont dominé
les débats mais ils se sont fait très
peur dans cette rencontre face à des
saint quentinois qui n'ont rien lâché
ils se sont imposés dans les dix
dernières minutes grâce à deux essais le
score final 32 à 24 on écoute les
réactions quand même la fierté parce que
on savait que ça va être compliqué c'est
une équipe qui joue le haut de tableau
et malgré tout les a tenus on les a
tenues avec nos armes avec le jeu et la
solidarité après dommage ça nous ça nous
sourit pas mais on va continuer à
travailler avait retourné on était
optimiste on a gagné mais sans manquer
de se manquer de respect aux sky je
pense que c'est normal qu'on gagne
largement est par contre
voilà qui n'est pas le bonus ça c'est
pas normal par comprendre au classement
chevreuse domine le championnat honneur
avec six victoires en huit matches de
son côté le sky rugby reste 7e avec 15
points et deux équipes joueront leur
dernière rencontre de l'année ce
dimanche 16 décembre
victoire impérative pour passer de
bonnes fêtes de fin d'année ces
informations sportives et bien d'autres
encore retrouvé dans un instant dans
votre émission de 7,8 sport merci
michael est ce que vous aimez noël si
j'imagine que oui vous avez prévu de
quoi quoi enfin petit repas en famille
rien de plus en tout cas on allait plus
cadeau j'espère que cadre on l'espère en
attendant vous pouvez le fêté de façon
décalée ce noël puisque la commanderie l
encours propose la première édition de
son noël décalé et solidaire ce week-end
s'ouvrait à l'exposition et des
premières activités et des festivités
qui vont se poursuivre toute la semaine
jusqu'au 16 décembre les détails de
marylène yapi scheer drôle de sapins et
drôle d'ange dix artistes ont revisité
ses traditionnelles décorations des
fêtes de fin d'année pour le noël décalé
de la commanderie
l'exposition entièrement composé de
matériaux de récupération s'est ouverte
samedi dans la chapelle
c'était un peu notre rôle de proposer un
noël différent à noël avec des artistes
samaël avec des amateurs noël avec aussi
des parents enfants puisque on a aussi
des propositions en famille notamment un
atelier lantern flottante
durant deux heures les enfants
apprennent à construire leurs lanternes
avant d'éteindre la lumière pour l'en a
fait 12 des feuilles en tout et on a
on a on a collé tout puis on a mis une
pastille on a mis du polystyrène en
dessous et puis on a mis une bougie des
lanternes qu'ils pourront déposer sur la
pièce d'eau de la commanderie ce samedi
15 décembre avec tous les participants
de l'atelier les enfants ça super
content en ça coûte vraiment pas cher et
puis voilà toute une construction qui
s'est fait à la main avec eux pour
l'arracher cette magnifique
les festivités se poursuivent et
s'intensifient jusqu'au 16 décembre avec
des concerts des stands solidaire et
même des activités plus surprenante
nous aurons un sauna alors un sauna
mobile à la manière du bagnard us donc
une petite caravane qui va être placé à
côté de la pièce d'eau de la commanderie
où vous pourrez venir faire un vrai
sauna entre amis trois places possibles
le nouvel décalé de la commanderie est
présent jusque dans la cour avec un
arbre à mot auquel participent chaque
visiteur c'est la fin du set 8 journal
belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]